female cyclists competing in a race in
Belgium was told to pause after she
almost caught up with the male athletes
who set off ten minutes before her
Nicole Hanselman from Switzerland took
an early lead in an annual race around
the Flemish our den but was made to pull
over at the side of the road so race
organisers could re-establish the gap
between the two groups its course huge
consternation on social media but what
actually happened and where the
organisers in the wrong the cyclist
herself joins us now from Zurich hello
to you thank you for joining us I was
furious when I saw this on Twitter tell
me what happened
actually it was quite the usual
situation so I got up if the men's punch
I had suddenly much more cars in front
of me so they let me sarah was calling
me next to his car neutralized the race
was a it's nothing too close to the
men's so because you were better than
the men they made you stop I think I'm
not better than then it's just the man
started really slow and we start yes
that's very humble of you I'm not sure
that that's necessarily true how much
did that put you off your stride at that
moment I was already away from the bunch
for maybe thirty days I was in a quite
good flow just right - and and you have
to stop it wait for 10 minutes it's like
yeah you just get really out of the flow
you pull down and then you have to start
again well you cross were you angry were
you frustrated how did you feel yeah
actually I was not angry at all with the
organisation because it's like if you
have to wait because of those rail rains
and but did it take did it yeah I mean
it you've slowed down and you had to
stop and so you were cold and you you
were in your stride previously you knew
exactly what you were doing you have the
race presumably mapped out in your head
and then somebody stands in front of you
and says oh no you have to wait here for
10 minutes because the men are not quick
enough yeah it's like I accepted it at
that point because it was still 90 case
to go and we didn't reach any of the
cobblestone sections or climbs till then
so the race will be changed anyway and I
was not expecting that I can go through
with my capsule I just take it as a
break and then yeah one after us has
this happened to you before
not because of medicines what happened
in the end of the race what happened
when you were allowed to restart so we
got the same time gaps we had before
Terra neutralisation servant with my
1:40 in the bunch huh and it was a bit
yeah a difficult situation creep for me
because the first couple standard
section was coming five days later so I
knew that the bunch will just go fool
Gus behind me and then it's difficult to
keep the gap did you win no do you think
it was because you were stopped no it's
like if you watch men's race early
breakaways has always a hard stand to
get su and I didn't expect that I will
win it because I did it to make the race
more attractive yeah yeah yeah final
thought what would you say to the men
that were in front of you if you could
speak to them
they should just start a bit faster yeah
exactly
go faster boys and then you can carry on
with your race I'm glad to see that
you're still smiling good for you I
think I would've been a little bit more
cross than you good luck in your next
race we appreciate you taking the time
to join us thank you